I would love to discuss Rogan's
statement about uh Trump on Lex
Freeman's podcast did y'all see that why
don't you ask him that question when he
came on our podcast I was high
I wrote it down as one of the questions
I was supposed to [ __ ] ask but he got
me so goddamn high and drunk that I
forgot to ask it yeah you know what I'm
saying yeah I do know okay [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay Lex has notes there he's
very smart damn yeah yeah come on not
smart enough to not have notes
now shout out to you Lex we want Lex on
the Pod man all right what do y'all
think though I loved it dude because
it's like you say the statement should
we watch it so yeah let's watch the clip
because I don't want to miss anything
um by the way I'm not a trump supporter
in any way shape or form I've had the
opportunity to have them on my show more
than once I've said no every time I
don't want to help him I'm not
interested in helping the the Knight is
still young we'll see if I have them on
tonight is still young yeah I think I'll
have them on yeah I think you'll have
them on really why do you think that
because you'll have Putin on
and you're competitive as [ __ ] no
so that was basically the clip he says
more stuff later on but uh yeah that's
like the just that's like what all the
headlines are saying yeah I believe them
I mean I know for a fact yeah I love it
that he said it publicly because
everybody keeps trying to do this Rogan
is his right wing he's Maggie he's this
he's that yeah and then the things he
say keep contradicting that more and
more blatantly and now what's your what
are you gonna say yeah now what are you
gonna say some of his followers are okay
everybody's followers are if you're big
enough it's impossible to have purely
amazing people following you yeah and
it's also like clearly the hip pieces on
him are coming from one political side
yes and
I they would never want to admit this
but like it's impossible that you are
half of the politics in America and
there's nothing to be criticized about
like there are things that the Democrats
you can criticize this for and I think
even AOC and Bernie have pointed this
out about their own party yeah and
they've gotten in trouble by their own
party because of it yeah are they Maga
you know what I'm saying like so it's an
easy way to position someone especially
if you're apolitical that's the thing
about being apolitical is so [ __ ]
tricky is that when you say that you
don't have a specific side it's easy to
paint you yeah there's safety in numbers
if you go rob I'm a Democrat or I'm a
conservative it don't really matter what
else you do because you've already
decided what team you root for yes yeah
they can't decide for you when you're
out here in the middle you gotta really
ride or die that middle and just ignore
the noise because both sides will start
to position you as the eyes but they
don't realize that that's the worst
strategy to do like if you are if you're
intuitive if you're a true the worst
thing you can do for conservativism is
criticize anybody who doesn't have a
purely conservative take on things like
I'm con fiscally conservative so and so
conservative but I'm pro-choice and then
you go oh this guy's a Democrat that
makes all the people in the middle go
you know what [ __ ] this whole party and
I think the left has been guilty of that
for the past whatever 10 years not that
the right is never done it but the left
loudly has been like oh if you're if you
don't believe in the vaccine you must be
Mega that's what it is now my question
to you is what wins an election do you
win an election by appealing to the
middle because of your values or making
the opposition so radioactive that the
middle is afraid to vote for them
I think it's by getting the moderates
like but the Democrats whole strategy in
2016 was make Trump radioactive yeah
that's my question that didn't work so
no they're just one Baseline well
Hillary get lost
Hillary was also radioactive that's the
thing interesting so it's like and then
with Joe Biden just like the most
neutral [ __ ] the worst thing you
can say about him is he's racist and
there's some conservative [ __ ]
they're like all right yeah
you know light it up right and that's
why well I think the moderates looked at
Trump and were like this has gotten too
crazy
I'm not saying bad president good prep
whatever's happening right now if this
calms it down to not vote for this guy
I'm not voting for this guy so so that's
so that's my question is is it more
effective to appeal to the group based
on your values meaning hey don't you
agree with me or we agree with how you
feel or
make them terrified of supporting your
opposition by calling him a racist a
tyrant whatever and then if you vote for
him that means you supported a racist
Tyrant or whatever it seems like the
Democrats were like we ain't gonna get
everybody on board with the [ __ ] that
we're doing but what we can do is make
that [ __ ] over there so awful
and he's going to make it easy for us
because he's going to say wild awful
[ __ ] that's the thing because uh Obama
was pretty eccentric that's what I'm
saying it almost feels like so go say no
I was just saying so it's like he ran
and [ __ ] won by a landslide appealing
to everybody hey these are my values my
view is appealing to everybody and then
kind of trump won the first time like
making the other side radioactive so
it's like I think you can win with Egypt
either strategy works I wonder if we're
at a point now
where like politics was like the right
and left was so much closer when Obama
won the first time yeah if Robbie was
making Obama radioactive I wonder how
that would have gone
explain on it like if they tried
you see me trying to make a move on go
on that I was like I can't say go on
that
explain on that yeah
explain on that go I mean I guess with
like but it wasn't him though it was
like Trump and like other
like Republicans that were like oh he's
Muslim he's a terrorist he wasn't born
here all that yeah all that stuff but it
wasn't Romney necessarily in my from my
memory like going at Obama being like oh
he's gonna destroy the country he's
going to ruin everything it seemed like
it was much more diplomatic then yo
even the the thing about him being not
from here right the birtherism
it doesn't exactly make you radioactive
unless you tie that to something that
could be dangerous to America yeah we
look at that now and it's like a very
tame insult like a 50 years are gonna be
like that was born here yeah and then
the last election like nobody was born
here right like Ted Cruz wasn't born
here Joe Biden's a pedophile
right Hillary Clinton's a pedophile like
and that's it just gets crazier and
crazier so so but when when Obama was
running I think you could run in a much
more neutral way because the issues were
a lot closer right like Obama was on the
first term didn't even have to say [ __ ]
about gay marriage he was like yeah I
already believe in that [ __ ] fam yeah
and then things progressed and then he
was like I changed my mind boom change
your mind good but
I guess what I'm saying is like the
division between the parties is massive
yeah so almost just believing and taking
the party line now is radioactive to the
opposite side right like simply by going
like I believe in abortion this side is
like the real conservative like
religious folks on this side are like
you are wild yeah like because they're
literally going you're killing babies
yeah like you're the crazy when you
believe in that yeah that's crazy yeah
so I wonder if now we're at a stage
where being that neutral Force
politically
won't work because you'll alienate
everyone
the folks on the left are like what do
you mean you understand their point
about abortion and the folks on the
right are like what do you mean you
would consider keeping it around what's
also tricky about it structurally is the
primaries the primaries that's just your
party voting so the extreme people win
the primary win the primary and then you
got two extremes going at it and then
it's just this is what's left for us to
vote for in the actual election yo
that's that's a great [ __ ] point the
primary system ensures the most extreme
version of the candidate because you
only vote in your party yeah that's I
never thought about like but then they
always start to shift their views once
they win that's where Trump changed
everything some [ __ ] they win the
primary then it's like Oh My Views are
starting to shift a little bit and then
all the people that were [ __ ] on the
primaries and suddenly they all love
each other
I want a spot in the White House yeah so
Hillary and Obama that was like they
were going at it son then all of a
sudden she's Secretary of State or
whatever the [ __ ] all right guys we
didn't take a break for a second because
I gotta tell you all about the best wall
in the business and it's extra this is a
no-brainer okay all my things in here
all my things in here and they're in
here and safe did you know that nobody
can come by and just boot me do you know
what a Boop is you go pay for something
just tap your little card right what
does that reader do takes your credit
card information well do it on the
street could do that to you unless
you've got this [ __ ] protected like
extra got it protected RFID protection
thank you nerds I'd be knowing but
that's important to know about that's
your information right here 100 you
can't let that [ __ ] get out there in the
world get it boobed 100 they're skimming
yeah that's the proper term for that
[ __ ] also if I lose this what happens
you can track it are you saying I can
never lose my wallet and son you can
never lose your wallet I mean can we
just repeat that one more time you're
saying there's a wallet out there where
I could never lose my wallet there's a
wallet out there you can never lose your
wallet that's crazy it's incredible
that's crazy because [ __ ] be
losing their wallet it's not I'd be
losing [ __ ] all the time but not your
wallet nah but this simple as that
because we got trackers on this now what
happens if the battery goes for the
tracker oh I think it's solar powered oh
so they ain't no battery oh just a sun
and you just leave that [ __ ] out and
then all of a sudden boom for months
your [ __ ] is good 100 this is the best
wallet on the planet incredible it's
actually the best wallet on the planet
and they even got this little money band
band somebody gonna dance
so so the point that I'm trying to make
right now is you could check out the
wallets at extra.com that's
ekster.com and you can get up to 20 off
site wide when you use the code flagrant
not even up to they're just giving you
20. is that right he's giving you 20.
God damn generous generous ass people so
20 off the best wall in the business the
best wall in the business anything on
site 20 off look at that
that's extra let's get back to the show
it's the code flagrant use that cold
flagrant let's get back to the show and
so you bring that up with Joe because if
you see him as a Centrist Force it's so
easy to paint him because he isn't
taking on one side right it's because he
is
he has so many he has so many like
things that he believes in and cares
about on both sides but it's so easy for
his opposition
to paint him as a conservative because
he's not going I am this and he's not
saying I'm with y'all
but it's a little dangerous because he
has spoken out and says hey I would
support Bernie and now you're coming out
and saying I'm not going to help this
guy and he went out it's kind of like
picking us up well even further he went
out and said I'd [ __ ] with DeSantis he
also said you'd be a good president so
this guy don't know nothing
Fear Factor podcast they never bring you
up though whenever they talk about it so
they never bring up like oh he's also
supported candidates Andrew Schultz
that's true that seems like media bias I
feel like I feel like they they're
afraid of me yeah in a lot of ways yo
they are you're a threat I'm a threat
you're a threat to the system I'm a
threat to National Security in a lot of
ways Not Gonna Get You elected oh [ __ ]
you're just you're upset the traditional
Powers you know what I mean yeah I upset
the traditional keep on telling me that
so like so like if you're looking for if
you're tired of the same old same old
there's one guy that's different listen
no Italian as president bro I don't even
know you just I know
you just started talking for no [ __ ]
okay okay let me just what was that [ __ ]
one more time they understand Andrew's a
threat you gotta disrupt the forces in
Nancy Pelosi's shirt that are already
there okay that's what we have to do you
have to go and Shake It Up listen please
shake it aren't you tired of the same
old political people rhetoric aren't you
tired of the same old political rhetoric
aren't you tired of Nancy Pelosi
plundering the stock market with her
husband and plunging give me one of
these they all talk like that yeah you
deserve to plunder the stock market as
well yeah right yeah make insider
trading legal you deserve to inside
train yeah tax World tax world's legal
when I'm president tax fraud will be
rewarded it shouldn't only be for the
billionaires it's not only for the
billionaires it's for you too everybody
gets a jet look under your seat
look under your seat under my seat
there's a jet under your [ __ ]
seat at home at home at the office come
on
Healthcare yeah everybody gets health
care who don't get health care yeah son
you got Health Care everybody gets
Health Indian doctors only yo absolutely
every Indian is a doctor now yeah Indian
is a doctor now you can walk up to any
Indian from India ask them to fix you
and they will do it done done and they
have to legally Legally they have to do
it or
they get put to the reservation they're
getting sent back yeah you're gonna be
singing songs on the corner with your
eyes poked out
I thought my solution was a little more
mild what yeah I thought my solution was
a little more Middle Road you know what
I mean but I I wanted to add some steaks
they're not gonna be in the middle of
the road dangerous why you gotta add
beef to Indians why you gotta do that
all right never do that yeah
illegal aliens illegal all I'm trying
all illegal aliens all illegal aliens
yeah will be
sent to area 51. oh where they can then
meet the real aliens oh [ __ ] we'll have
them battle it out uh for a place in
America oh that's kind of cool they'll
most likely will be taken from the
Native Americans
okay that's the new reservation we'll
reserve it for
the UFO people yes
what else
abortion abortion yes mandatory I'm
doing it
floor seats for the Nets
a strong campaign Andrews shows.com yeah
do you know what I'm saying I think we
got a strong campaign they're gonna make
some enemies though Trump came for uh
Rogan what the [ __ ] did he allegedly
this is what he said he said let me talk
a statement by Donald J Trump 45th
president of America here in that lion
Joe Rogan doesn't want me to be on his
podcast he said that he asked he said
that he was asked more than once to have
me on lies he asked me many times but I
said no he would be lucky to have
records setting America's greatest
present as a guest it would be
record-setting and smart business for
Spotify lion Joe would rather have
second rape president like gutless Ron
DeSantis on his low rated show this
[ __ ] be lying bro yo I didn't
realize how much he lied until this this
[ __ ] be lying bro did y'all know
Donald J Trump lied I didn't know that's
a lie you're a liar
he's never lied before he's never lied
[ __ ] be lying what's your
favorite verse in the Bible he didn't
lie yeah he said all of them Loki how
are you going how are you going picking
I was telling the truth about grabbing
[ __ ] though
that was a fib he fibbed a little no
that wasn't a fifth he would never do he
was telling that truth he was telling
that truth sometimes you got to grab a
hunka really you gotta have a hunk of it
you've never been at the candy store you
go get some Sour Patches with your
fingers
wait you don't use a scooper [ __ ] a
scooper bro this is pre-covered that's
gross I come right from
you still pick your ass pre-covered
that's nasty oh dude I was digging I
know I keep my nails short because when
they're long I get too much doodoo
inside yo does this smell sometimes you
ever smell your own hands biting his
nails so that's right no you eat [ __ ] no
I don't yeah you do yeah it's just the
same food yeah but it is it's just other
people it's not your own dude yeah yo
but that's crazy you could just lie like
that that is why wait why do you imagine
politicians just lying like that that
might be I don't know no it's probably
fake it's fake I don't think he's ever
caught because he would never lie yeah
honestly because he don't want smoke
with Joe I don't know brother santis
like he hasn't like publicly
they're still in their little uh secret
War right now they're yeah they're
having that like
but is that tweet real
yeah
it's public no it's public but I'm
talking about like that statement right
there not as real bro Trump is yeah no
so according to Snopes which is also
fake news yep it says it originated as
satire
that's that's fake yeah that's fake come
on Mark come on Dove why are you letting
truth get in the way I knew he would
never lie oh my God thank God
guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay can we please can we please just
button up this discussion yeah button it
up yo why isn't Trump saying anything
that's a little [ __ ] that [ __ ]
be saying [ __ ] all the time but nobody
goes to his little uh truth website or
whatever truth
why doesn't he just tweet through his
son
he probably does he does yo that's like
official statements you know just get
back on Twitter stop being [ __ ] yeah
bruh be throwing these little Hissy Fits
right also yeah you could just get back
on Twitter right like you can make it
back make a burner I think he's back huh
he's back on IG I know that I think Elon
said he'd bring him back but Elon has
been Stalin for some reason yeah what's
the deal with that yeah I don't know he
didn't want to buy no [ __ ] Twitter
you know I think they call me he's a
busy guy I'll buy it right now they're
like all right suck my dick all right I
will she's like [ __ ] this guy's gotta
suck my dick now yeah not good time
especially with the economy going like
this because I think he would have to
like put up shares for the company Tesla
stock now yeah you'd have to I'ma [ __ ]
this up but I'll do my best he has to
put up Tesla's stock in order the loan
right now
if that Tesla stock tanks obviously yeah
it's not as secure as it was at the
higher price for the loan so he would
there could be a run on the stock or
whatever the [ __ ] it is and then the
bank could say yo we need our money
we're not we don't trust your Tesla
stock anymore yeah Margin Call Margin
Call and then you got to pay all that
money or you lose [ __ ] everything you
know all that [ __ ] well I'm learning I'm
learning God damn are you like reading
books about us no my homie was telling
me that's how he got a [ __ ] Mercedes
bitcoin's going down a traditional stock
market
what am I going to do guys yeah no
you're saying this is brilliant way to
get money at low low interest rates is
like put your stock against it so you
take like a hundred thousand dollar loan
if you got that much in stock and he's
like the thing I do is it's money I can
afford to pay if I have to but he got a
Benz electric at like 1.4 interest
that's only the best Indians come here
bro let's [ __ ] go saying I got you